Chad we have a quote here from someone
which is an unlikely person to go for
acting but it's from David Bowie and I
just found it the other day I thought it
was interesting and the quote said as
you get older questions come down to
about two or three things how long and
what do I do with the time that I have
left and the reason this kind of stuck
out to me was I'm just thinking about it
my own life yeah so I'm just wondering
for you does this bring up anything
interesting just cuz you know life
changes after the 20s and this is yeah
and I just turned 40 and so that
question definitely looms Siple how much
longer how am I going to go what what
more do I have to do here there's a lot
to do I feel like 40 is the new 20 maybe
I don't know you know it makes me
reflect on all of my time that I've that
I've spent in Los Angeles and pursuing
an acting career and I look back and I'm
like thank God because when you're young
you don't really realize what you're
getting into you know and I kind of had
my blinders on and I'm like well nothing
is gonna get here I'm gonna go and do it
and I'm very lucky that it happened
because it doesn't happen for a lot of
people so 22 years in I'm like but it's
still just as hard as it was okay well I
mean you're incredibly young 40 thank
you you know thank you sign yeah yeah
now do you think maybe there'll be new
roles maybe not
Jesse or maybe Jesse you reinvented
right but but now there's a whole new
thing open to you as a 40 year old male
right
you can still pass for away everybody
right knowing I appreciate that I can't
do high school anymore
I'm pushing college but definitely
weren't for me when I was younger I mean
I played you know I was 20 playing 15
you know so now I can still play
thirties but it definitely lends
mean to do more interesting roles I
think now because I have grown into
myself I Know Who I am
much more confident in Who I am you know
when you're in that twenty late 20s 30s
I kind of squandered a bit because I'm
like why don't really fit here and I
don't really fit here so now that I've
come into my 40s I feel very confident
about where I'm going so what did you
think you didn't fit in because I don't
see you that way but I'm just curious
whereas I could see the fitting into so
many rules but um well I wasn't quite a
man as funny as that sounds you know I'm
in my 30s and in my early 30s but a
really tough time in this business
because I I started out by getting big
roles right away I mean I started
working my first audition I books and
you know my career started to kind of
like here and then as I was 30 I kind of
had to backtrack a little bit and sort
of sort out what a lot of actors go
through in the beginning of their
careers trying to get the hustle and so
I kind of had to like step back a little
bit and reassess everything so I wasn't
quite an older guy you know to play this
role and I wasn't quite young enough I
was just kind of interesting enough my
early 30s it was an awkward stage for me
weird as that is
you